the X-Force definitive guide to
ransomware and IBM consulting's Center
of Excellence for generative AI all on
this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
ransomware is experiencing a Renaissance
in 2023 with some cyber security firms
reporting over 400 attacks in the month
of March alone
and this shouldn't be a surprise the
2023 X-Force threat intelligence index
found that backdoor deployments were the
top attacker action in 2022 and the
report predicted 2022's backdoor
failures would become 2023's ransomware
crisis
simply put the cybercrime ecosystem is
becoming industrialized allowing
adversaries to complete more attacks
faster
luckily the 2023 X-Force definitive
guide to ransomware can help
threat actors continue to adjust their
tactics techniques and procedures to
evade detection to stay ahead we refresh
the guide annually to include the latest
ransomware research Trends and attack
types
in this year's Edition you'll find the
X-Force exclusive five-stage ransomware
attack framework developed from real
life engagements combating the threat
fortified background on ransomware's
evolution in 2023 and X-Force
proprietary research including detection
techniques that can help you discover
and prevent ransomware on your network
to learn more about how to protect
yourself from ransomware and download
the guide hit the link below
next up generative AI maybe you've heard
of it it's kind of a big deal in Tech
right now so in order to help our
clients harness the power of AI in your
business Transformations IBM Consulting
has established a center of excellence
for generative AI
the center of excellence already has
more than a thousand Consultants with
specialized generative AI expertise that
are engaging with a global set of
clients
in recent research 79 of Executives said
their organization is challenged with
ensuring their AI models are responsible
secure and free from discrimination and
bias
they're very reasonable concerns around
Ai and how to mitigate bias manage data
security and factor in precision and
risk
our years of AI experience show us that
getting to Enterprise AI at scale
requires a composable multi-model
strategy and a human-centric principled
approach
luckily our Consultants have developed
deep skills in applying an ethically
responsible approach to Ai and
delivering business value
in fact IBM Consulting has already
worked with more than 100 clients and
completed dozens of engagements infusing
generative AI alongside classical
machine learning AI strategies
to learn more about the center of
excellence for generative AI hit the
link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now